the category for Final Jeopardy today is
needless analysis of classic game shows
here's the clue jeopardy champ James
Holt's our 1:32 matches and broke the
game of Jeopardy using this secret
method we had a strategy I thought it
was just a robot
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that gives you your daily
double of pop culture and incisive
research most of the time on film Theory
I cover movies and shows that really
capture the imagination Marvel
superheroes Disney's Darkseid internet
creepypastas but today I'm going back to
my roots that's right I'm talking about
game shows for really the first time
since I tried it like eight years ago on
a one-off episode of game theory where
I'm like here let's talk about these
games in this game show and everyone was
like these aren't video games and I'm
like yeah but they're games any game
show format actually probably more
useful cuz I could teach you how to win
tens of thousands of dollars on like The
Price is Right and everyone's like no
that sucks and I'm like all right well I
guess I don't get to talk about that
thing that I really like to talk about
so bottle it up inside man until today
and in a part two episode that will
undoubtedly underperform on this channel
but you know what I just thought it was
really interesting because jeopardy is
rigged anyway rant over back to my
pre-scripted intro game shows were one
of my earliest TV loves little matpat
spent many a day curled up in front of
the glow of Wheel of Fortune prices
right especially and the king of them
all jeopardy now I know that not many of
you watched jeopardy because let's face
it not many of you are over 75 but
jeopardy is having a huge cultural
resurgence
I mean first off Netflix just picked up
like every episode of Jeopardy ever
created because people are just really
excited to watch jeopardy on Netflix
reason but also and more importantly
because NBC's 7 p.m. grandma bait has
been playing out like a telenovela of
the gameshow world over the past year
picture this professional sports bettor
James comes on to jeopardy for the first
time on April 4th 2019 no one knows that
he's taken a full year off to study and
prepare for these games he comes in
completely up ends how the entire game
of Jeopardy esplen psa's with his bold
and weirdly charming yet robotic social
awkwardness
he goes on to win 32 games in a row and
even Alex Trebek feels badly for people
who have to play against him he breaks
every Jeopardy high score record known
to mankind since the show began in 1964
single-handedly redefining what it meant
to win big on a TV game show with a
total payout of two million four hundred
and sixty-two thousand two hundred and
sixteen dollars who wants to be a
millionaire eat your heart out he wanted
to be a millionaire twice over and did
it he accomplishes this massive total by
averaging get this seventy six thousand
nine hundred and forty four dollars of
winning every single game the previous
single day scoring record for a game of
Jeopardy was seventy seven thousand
dollars a record that James himself
broke 16 times during course of his run
but just as he's one game away from
breaking that all-time earnings record
of Jeopardy taking over the crown held
by the famous 10 Jennings himself who
did it in over 70 games he is suddenly
unceremonious Lise knifed by a research
librarian the story leaves us with two
main questions one how the heck did
James managed to reinvent jeopardy a
game show that's been running for the
better part of a century and - was he
really defeated or did NBC rigged the
game to make sure that he was kicked off
before he basically bankrupted the show
did James just have a lucky run with an
unlucky ending or was there a lot more
going on here behind the scenes than all
the Jeopardy viewers could see through
their heavily bifocal Glenn's ins get
ready my friends because at the end of
this two-part series we might just have
exposed the greatest conspiracy to ever
happen
show history final jeopardy indeed let's
talk about James's strategy first there
has been a lot of jeopardy contestants
over the years and if you've watched the
show you know that 99% of players play
in a very low-risk way as a refresher on
Jeopardy you have five trivia categories
with five questions each and the
questions get harder as you go down each
column you pick which category and
dollar amounts that you want to go for
get the question right get the money
choose again get it wrong and lose the
money because losing money is an option
in this game most players tend to bed
pretty conservatively at first testing
out the category by picking the easy low
value questions first except for James
he was one of the first players ever to
take the completely opposite approach
first he almost always started at the
highest value clues way down at the
bottom of the board and then he would
move his way up to the smaller numbers
this allowed him to get ahead fast very
early on not only racking up his own
score but also keeping the other players
from catching up because all the
high-value questions were already taken
next he also jumped from category to
category now most people will find a
category that they're comfortable with
and then try to run through all the
questions in it this makes sense because
instead of switching from one topic to
the next you can think all the way
through a category and hopefully answer
all the questions right but rather than
let his opponents get into a groove on a
specific topic James
forced them to jump from pop music to
European history to rhyme time a method
that seemed to work for him but often
discombobulated his opponents James has
said in interviews that he used
children's books to study facts about
everything from pop culture to geography
practice quizzing himself across a huge
range of subjects giving himself the
flexibility to hop from category to
category well his opponents were still
trying to remember that European capital
city from two questions ago the strategy
that he's exploiting in this case is a
function of the brain called task
switching which is the brain's ability
to switch attention from one thing to
another it's well-documented in
psychology research that when people do
the same task over and over and over and
over again their speed will increase and
their errors will decrease make them
shift back and forth and they suddenly
get both slower and worse at the tasks
taking this and applying it to jeopardy
there's only two categories like ends a
nation and British monarchs it's both
easier and faster for your brain to
figure out each additional answer when
you stick in the same category you're in
the groove or on a roll but James of
course didn't do that by constantly
moving around the board he triggered in
his opponent's what's called a switch
cause which in this case is the
additional time and effort it takes the
brain to process information when there
has been a switch of some form
so James whose entire training was all
about switching topics very quickly was
much more adept and able to do this on
the fly but his opponents who weren't
trained to that gameplay style were left
holding the bag they were left at a
disadvantage and tripping over their own
feet so already James is not only
playing the statistics of jeopardy by
choosing high-value items at the bottom
of the board but he's also playing the
meta game of Jeopardy by playing the
other players using the human brains
built-in weaknesses against his
opponents on top of all of that whether
it was intentional or not James didn't
just jump around he looked like he was
trying to do it as fast as possible
before alex trebek was even done telling
James his last answer was right he
usually had lined up what clue he was
choosing next he'd spit it out as fast
as possible one example from game 23 of
James's run after getting a question
right James called out his next choice
as sports eight instead of the real name
of the category let's go to that sports
thing for 800 maybe James just didn't
want to say a category name as goofy as
let's go to that sports thing for 800
but a much likelier explanation is that
he's just trying to use a breakneck pace
against his opponents he's switching and
he's switching quickly using this sort
of strategy from the very first question
James was in the lead by over $8,000 on
average after the first round all those
things combined make that player of
force to be reckoned with but James
wasn't content with just that he had one
more card up his sleeve a trump card
that made him unbeatable he bet what
seemed like reckless amounts on all his
daily doubles he bet way larger amount
than almost anyone in the history of the
show so that when he'd get a Daily
Double right his score would double
putting him so far in the lead that it
was literally literally impossible for
any contestant to catch up with just the
remaining dollar amounts on the board
now here James was also playing with an
advantage he stated that because of his
job as a sports bettor
literally someone who is paid to play
smart bets on sporting events and
players he's used to gambling with huge
amounts of money he said that for him
seen a $60,000 wager doesn't faze him
because he's become desensitized to
numbers that large where for most of us
we'd look at that number and see it as a
down payment on a house or 60,000 single
hamburgers at McDonald's just something
that's way too precious to bet away on a
whim so he was the only one willing to
make bets that big because he was
psychologically primed to do it
luckily for him though that strategy
doesn't just work psychologically it
also works out mathematically over
James's 32 wins he got to answer 75 of
the 96 daily doubles and he answered him
correctly at a ninety four point seven
percent accuracy rate he almost never
missed them so frankly for him there was
much less risk to betting big odds were
that no matter how much he wagered he
gets an answer right but even when James
did miss the answer the rest of his
statistics indicated that he would be
able to make a comeback James was the
first to buzzin to answer fifty eight
point three percent of the time which is
pretty darn impressive we didn't
consider that the other 41.7% was split
monks to other opponents so on average
he was getting to answer more than
double the number of questions of his
other two opponents and when James
buzzed and he wasn't likely to miss his
overall accuracy rate over the course of
the run was a mind-boggling 97 percent
it can be hard to contextualize just how
crazy that correct answer rate is but
remember when I mentioned Ken Jennings
earlier who won 74 consecutive jeopardy
games he is the most famous gameshow
player in history and his accuracy rate
was ninety one point seven percent
meaning that he missed questions about
three times as often as James that's
insane
imagine the greatest player in any sport
or game or other quantifiable contest
whether that's Muhammad Ali in boxing or
Serena Williams in tennis or Grand who
bear and video games speedrunning now
imagine someone else coming along and
making one third of the mistakes of the
person consider to be the best of all
time
that is crazy sure it's just a
difference of ninety-one percent to
ninety seven percent but that is eight
huge difference there James just comes
in and crushes the game with a level of
knowledge that no one has ever seen
before but to sum up what that insane
accuracy and buzz rate means in the
context of a Jeopardy game if James made
a big bet on a Daily Double early on in
the game and lost everything based on
his statistics he was gonna answer about
six of the next 10 clues correctly
whereas his opponents would only get one
or two piece people who watched James
knew that when he got a lead he tended
to keep it and expand it aggressively
but the data would also suggest that in
the rare instances when he was coming
from behind he could make up a deficit
quickly so you can see how all the
pieces of his strategy work together to
make him a crazy difficult player to
beat 32 times in a row and that sort of
record leads to James's biggest edge of
all intimidation bully didn't step into
his very first game with the reputation
of being a jeopardy wizard it didn't
take long for James's reputation as a
high scoring big betting buzzer swinging
outlaw to be established part of the
reason for that is that jeopardy films
several episodes in a day meaning that
the players that James would face on
Friday got to watch him annihilate the
poor saps from Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday before diving into the deep end
with him and even when those players put
up a fight it didn't seem to make that
big of a difference take it from
Marshall Shelburne who described playing
against James like this quote my main
emotion during the game was frustration
there were many many times where I felt
like I timed it just right hit it right
on the lights in every single time he
was one step ahead of me and now I'm not
accusing any of James's opponents of
intentionally giving up but behavioral
psychology would suggest that they were
probably inclined to and subliminally to
some extent they might have been the
theory of learned helplessness says that
when we experienced repeated negative
stimuli such as getting beaten on the
buzzer for the 12th time in a row we
eventually just accept our own
powerlessness in the situation and we
stopped a tempting to avoid whatever
negative stimulus that is a rat trapped
in a box where the floor is electrified
every once in a while and has nowhere to
escape he just gives into it he's like
well yes I'm getting electrified this
time sucks actually it's a really sad
thing for the mice same thing in a game
of Jeopardy the TLDR here is when you
get smacked around in a game of Jeopardy
for long enough and you see it happen to
other people you stop putting up that
much of a fight don't take
my word for it either Alex Trebek has
got me covered after one particular
record-setting game Trebek apparently
instructed James to look at the next
contestants coming out of the audience
and said quote look at them they're
going Oh poop we have to face James next
you can get everybody's favorite
mild-mannered television trivia uncle to
start dropping expletives you know that
you've won the intimidation game none of
these things individually is gonna
guarantee a win at best betting big and
switching categories and answering
faster gives players small edges but
that's the thing about James has a
professional gambler it's his job to
recognize and exploit small edges
he knows that betting on a team that'll
win fifty five percent of the time is
vastly superior to betting on a team
that'll win 52 percent of the time and
that this edge will be magnified the
more repetitions there are and James
kept repeating and repeating and
repeating so with all of this in mind
with odds literally in James's favor and
a massive winning streak under his belt
and a massive amount of money in his
pocket and a massive amount of knowledge
in his brainy head of his how did he
lose did someone just get lucky or as
many on the internet have suggested it's
something fishy happen James lives and
works as a gambler in Vegas and if
there's one thing that happens in Vegas
is that the house always wins when you
hit too many jackpots or win too many
hands a blackjack at a casino the only
thing you can count on is a tap on the
shoulder that's gonna tell you you've
played enough and it's time for you to
take your betting somewhere else the
casino or in our case NBC isn't in the
game to lose money and in the next
episode we'll be talking about all the
ways they tried to intentionally roust
James from the game so don't touch that
dial go grab your fix it in and your
gold Bond medicated powder and join us
for part two of this theory where all
questions will be answered just think of
this as a multi-day commercial break
that you can't fast forward through in
the meantime though I have a Jeopardy
clue for you answer is this is the best
way to stay informed of all the
loads happening on this channel what is
subscribing and ringing the bell yes oh
my gosh you're totally right Final
Jeopardy winner is you you should ring
that Bell hit subscribe make sure you're
notified of when part two of this theory
happens as well as all the other awesome
theories that we have here on this
channel we really run the gamut of
literally every topic that you could
possibly cover from YouTube webseries to
horror movies to Disney theories to
Marvel superhero it's literally anything
and everything goes here on the channel
so if you enjoyed this episode you're
gonna like the next one and everything
else we have come and hit that subscribe
button help us reach the 10 million mark
so we can get the glorified diamond
paperweight film theory deserves it and
in the meantime remember that's just a
theory
Oh film theory now here's a Jeopardy
question for you this is the best way to
stay warm and stylish this winter what
is the new round of game theory merch
that is correct I knew you're smart
James didn't let me down and once you
know it Holliday Theory where is
available right now below this video be
our handy dandy merch link in the top
line of the description we've got
everything from a game theory switch
case to a new version of one of our most
popular items of all time the hoodie
dress for girls want to be comfy and
cozy this winter snuggle up in our black
and green lounge pants planning on
heading out into the cold
check out our flight jacket one part
hoodie one part windbreaker
it's even got patches that you can swap
around with your friends so you can make
it a film theory and game theory jacket
or just a gamer jacket or heck a game
theory and jacksepticeye and markiplier
hoodie or it could just be for nap it's
omni merch because we made it modular
I'm just very excited about modular
merch hey did you really hate a certain
theory like a lot of the Star Wars
theories that end up wrong well you
could do what Stephanie did during the
merch shoot hit me with the box or you
could take it out on the map hat
collectible tumbler there's more to like
a t-shirt and ugly Christmas sweater to
wear to all your holiday parties all of
which are available right now just click
the link below or go to creator
dot-com hi NK comm forget Black Friday
make it theorists Friday quantities are
limited though so once they're gone
they're gone thank you all so much for
watching we'll see you next time for
jeopardy part 2 and remember is all just